and the Oscar goes to don't feel bad  about the Pixar people they have iPod  stock they're going to be okay the Oscar  goes to The Incredibles this is the  first Academy Award and second  nomination tonight for Bradbury  oh thank you so much I don't know what's  more frightening being watched by  millions of people or the hundreds of  people that are going to be annoyed with  me tomorrow for not mentioning them  tonight but I just want to thank the  Holy Trinity of Pixar my good friend  John Lasseter Ed Catmull Steve Jobs for  making the greatest studio on the face  of the earth and yeah and I want to  thank my producer John Walker and dick  cook and the great Disney marketing team  you know animation is about creating the  illusion of life and you can't create it  if you don't have one so I want to thank  my wonderful crew for the creation and I  want to thank my mom my dad my wife Liz  and my kids Jack Michael and Nick for  giving me my life I love you and thank  you